what if you could absorb another
organism and take on its abilities
imagine you swallowed a small bird and
suddenly gained the ability to fly or if
you engulfed a cobra and were then able
to spit poisonous venom from your teeth
throughout the history of life
specifically during the evolution of
complex eukaryotic cells things like
this happened all the time one organism
absorbed another and they United to
become a new organism with the combined
abilities of both
we think that around 2 billion years ago
the only living organisms on Earth were
prokaryotes single-celled organisms
lacking membrane bound organelles let's
look closely at just three of them
one was a big simple blob like cell with
the ability to absorb things by wrapping
its cell membrane around them another
was a bacterial cell that converted
solar energy into sugar molecules
through photosynthesis
a third used oxygen gas to break down
materials like sugar and release its
energy into a form useful for life
activities
The Blob cells would occasionally absorb
the little photosynthetic bacteria these
bacteria then lived inside the blob and
divided like they always had but their
existence became linked if you stumbled
upon this living arrangement you might
just think that the whole thing was one
organism that the green photosynthetic
bacteria were just a part of the blob
that performed one of its life functions
just like your heart is a part of you
that performs the function of pumping
your blood
this process of cells living together is
called endosymbiosis one organism living
inside another but the endosymbiosis
didn't stop there what would happen if
the other bacteria moved in too now the
cells of this species started becoming
highly complex they were big and full of
intricate structures that we call
chloroplasts and mitochondria these
structures works together to harness
sunlight make sugar and break down that
sugar using the oxygen that right around
this time started to appear in the
Earth's atmosphere organisms absorbing
other organisms was one way species
adapted to the changing environmental
conditions of their surroundings this
little story highlights what biologists
call the endosymbiotic theory the
current best explanation of how complex
cells evolved there's a lot of evidence
that supports this theory but let's look
at three main pieces first the
chloroplasts and mitochondria in our
cells multiply the very same way as
those ancient bacteria which are still
around by the way in fact if you destroy
these structures in a Cell no new ones
will appear the cell can't make them
they can only make more of themselves
second piece of evidence chloroplasts
and mitochondria both contain their own
DNA and ribosomes their DNA has a
circular structure that is strikingly
similar to the DNA of the ancient
bacteria and it also contains many
similar genes the ribosomes or protein
assembly machines of chloroplasts and
mitochondria also have the same
structure as ribosomes of ancient
bacteria but are different from the
ribosomes hanging around the rest of the
eukaryotic cell lastly think about the
membranes involved in the engulfing
process chloroplasts and mitochondria
both have two membranes surrounding them
an inner and outer membrane their inner
membrane contains some particular lipids
and proteins that are not present in the
outer membrane why is that significant
because their outer membrane used to
belong to the blob cell
when they were engulfed in the
endosymbiosis process they got wrapped
up in that membrane and kept their own
as their inner one surely enough those
same lipids and proteins are found on
the membranes of the ancient bacteria
biologists now use this theory to
explain the origin of the vast variety
of eukaryotic organisms take the green
algae that grow on the walls of swimming
pools a larger eukaryotic cell with
spinning tail structures or flagella at
some point absorbed algae like these to
form what we now call you Glenna you
Glenna can perform photosynthesis break
down sugar using oxygen and swim around
pond water and as the theory would
predict the chloroplasts in these you
Glenna have three membranes since they
had two before being engulfed the
absorbing process of endosymbiotic
theory allowed organisms to combine
powerful abilities to become better
adapted to life on Earth
the results were species capable of much
more than when they were separate
organisms and this was an evolutionary
leap that led to the microorganisms
plants and animals we observe on the
planet today
you